We have explored the method
of string compression called
Burrows-Wheeler Transform that's going to let
us convert the repeats of a genome into runs,
so that we can apply some other
compression, such as run length encoding.
There is a strange observation in Burrows-Wheeler
Transform. For example, if we consider the
string “PANAMABANANAS”, you will notice
that, if we start with the last column,
we get the first column for free. For example,
the six occurrences of “As” is highlighted here.
In the first column, the 6 occurrences of
“As” also appear in the last column. Here,
we have highlighted where those “As” occur in sort
of these cyclic representation of “PANAMABANANAS”.
If we look at the first “A” in the first
column and the first “A” in the last column,
you'll notice that these two “As” correspond to
the same position in the string “PANAMABANANAS”,
which is the third “A” in “PANAMABANANAS”. You can
see that this pattern is consistent throughout.
We can look at the “Ns” too. It's not
something that's particular to “A”,
it's for any symbol. So if we look at the “Ns”,
the first appearance of “N” in the last column and
the first appearance of “N” in the first column,
they both correspond to the highlighted “Ns” here.
We will try to verify whether this property
of Burrows-Wheeler Transform hold in general.
If we look at the six columns that
start with an “A” and they're sorted.
If we chop off an “A”, the rows are still sorted.
This is because they all start with “A” and the
remainder of the strings are still sorted. Now,
if we add this “A” back to the end, then those
strings should still be sorted because all we
did was add an “A” to the end of all of them.
So we've essentially done a cyclic rotation of our
six original strings where we just took the “A”
and put it on the end, and those strings
remain sorted. What that means is,
if we look for those cyclic rotations back in the
original Burrows-Wheeler matrix wherever they are,
they should still maintain the same ordering.
In short, the k-th occurrence of any symbol in the
First Column and the k-th occurrence of any symbol
in the final column of the Burrows-Wheeler matrix
correspond to the exact same position of that
symbol in the original genome. So you can index
your occurrences of each symbol in the First and
Last Column. For example, the index of the sixth
“A” here in the first column is corresponding
to the sixth “A” here in the last column.
Same for the “Ns”. Index n1, n2 and n3 in
the first column here correspond to n1,
n2 and n3 in the last column here.
How does this relate to pattern matching? Here
is an example. Presumably we want to match the
string “ANA” to the genome string “PANAMABANANAS”,
we start from the last character, “A”. We look
in the first column and we can identify on the
rows that “A” appear. Then, the next character
“N”. We will look at the last column and our
search now limit to the string with N1, N2, and
N3. Using the first last property, we can also
identify where N1, N2, N3 appears in the first
column. So now, we have identified two letters.
The next is “A”. We just go back, and find
all “A”. Using the first last property,
and we can again know where the A3, A4, A5 appear
in the first column. In this case, the string
“ANA” appears three times, in the genome string.
In the previous example, we show that we can
identify which pattern match to the genome
using Burrows-Wheeler Transform. However,
for multiple pattern matching problem we also need
to find where is the pattern matches happened.
So the question is, can we use Burrows-Wheeler
Transform to reveal these positions?
If we go back to our example, we know that “ANA”
occurs 3 times in our genome, “PANAMABANANAS”.
If we're using Burrows-Wheeler, we
only have the first and the last column
and we don't know where it is that
these pattern matches are occurring.
So, we'll use a data selector called a suffix
array. To do this, we are going to identify the
starting position of each suffix at the beginning
of a row. Each row of the Burrows-Wheeler
transform corresponds to a cyclic rotation of our
original string. So, if it's a cyclic rotation,
then we can walk to some point and reach the
$ and that walking corresponds to a suffix.
For example, the first row is just the $ sign,
so it is the suffix at the end of the string
and that's in position 13, so we put a 13 on that
row. The next rows begins with “A” “BANANAS” and
the “A” “BANANAS” is in position 5 of the original
string, so we put a 5 in the second element of the
suffix array. If we go through this, we will
be able to construct an entire suffix array.
How is that helpful to find the matches?
Well, if we look at the three occurrences
“ANA” that we found, we can identify the
corresponding elements in the suffix array.
It tells us that “ANA” occurs at
positions 1, 7, and 9 of “PANAMABANANAS”.